[Music]
thank you for bidding on me in the
auction
i am so flattered that somebody your age
would be a fan of my work i don't know
who the hell you are my ex really wanted
to meet you so he bit
how much 22. 2200 that's fantastic 22
it started at 20 and then it went up in
50 cent increments
i'm a comedy writer all right guys very
funny stuff i also
write to broadway and movies why is your
face suddenly bigger than it was before
oh my god are you allergic to seafood oh
my god she doesn't have insurance and
she really shouldn't be leaving here by
herself
your daughter is going to be fine why do
you tell the doctor that i was your
father
i was a little loopy by then are you
doing anything right now
no went up some laughs come on queen
smile girl smile
marilyn monroe from the seven year rich
hmm i beat you too if i had hot subway
or blowing up my ass
doctor thanks for seeing me so late
how's the writing going it's all of
these young kids
in the tradition of george carlin and
richard pryor somebody's got to talk to
roger about his inflections
come on sub peanut what is that a very
small peanut
are you doing what you talked about i
try not to vary my routine you have
medicines to help you i was backed up
for like eight days and you can always
give yourself an enema
i'm saving that for my birthday
who are they that's my family if they're
your family why do you have their names
written down
charlie you can't be alone anymore if
you ever need my help i'm here
i'm writing something and i have to
finish before my words run out
i'll take care of them may i ask what
your relationship is i don't know i
don't know
do you live here i'm his friend but your
dad needs you right now
i mean this young woman is full of
surprises this is no time for jokes
it's the perfect time for jokes you
funny old man
everybody needs somebody
i want to have fun i want to laugh i
want to not be scared
and i want to write the book and i want
to do all of that with you
hell yeah everybody needs somebody
whoa huh i didn't want for this to
happen that this it didn't happen
your little frail body would not be able
to handle all these groceries i break
your back then you die
can't have it
[Music]
bye